so we think you're gonna kill us I'm
gonna do my best might not be in the
game in the game though hey guys - my
name is Jonathan Wendel also a fatality
I'm a 12-time world champion video gamer
a rich one of the most deadliest people
on internet the youtuber here named run
JB run and I love playing games like
Call of Duty Halo and also super smash
brothers hi my name is David Lana Gras
I'm a former in the United States Marine
Corps Special Operations sniper I served
six years in a special operations unit
I've actually never played call of duty
before I'm McHale Vega I spent 22 and a
half years in the military - bomb squad
half in the SEAL Teams so we're gonna
play a two-on-two deathmatch game where
basically you have two veterans versus
two professional gamers there's gonna be
a very interesting battle between the
teams and we'll see whose teamwork comes
on top I mean I think I have a lot of
real-world experience obviously so I
feel like that'll hopefully translate
well to the game
oh you can jump over stuff right no no
one do that put that [ __ ] back F&G down
you should be proud you should be really
proud
did you get a little damage I took a
little bit yeah I got a couple shots up
I'm trying to myself he kills me so fast
eat it payback I'm pretty happy with how
I did you guys are pretty good man I got
five killer I got I don't have any kills
but I got a shot off though
round two
from behind again you stab me or shoot
me I just shot somebody see they're
moving at the unit dude this is like
horseshit I just get moving tactically
and I get hit Oh what
forget the grenade dude that almost
killed dad I gotta get one fill man come
on oh my the F and G oh my god first
kill I almost did but you know what I
choked I hit the wrong button
do you actually almost touch JV at the
jump arms he's like running behind him
and then he runs into the fountain well
you think that's pretty [ __ ] funny
yes right for one more for the vets that
way all that I'm coming for you so what
you're saying is you're you're happy to
be killing vets no no no no that what
you're saying that what you're saying
[Music]
got me [ __ ] I thought thank you that's
a pro kill that one kill represents the
whole game they bet they won where they
killed a pro player payback somebody
wants to marry this who else just get
their dues somebody threw a grenade oh
[ __ ] where's the problem
no it's from the top where yet now god
but that was nothing compared to last
game I mean we got crushed I mean I can
barely use the controller I feel like I
was doing PT and jogging around the
whole time and then I squeeze off a
couple rounds and I get killed so that
was my experience with these
professional gamers I don't know what
Macau would like to add to that got to
pick those small victories like getting
a kill it's actually pretty impressed
him you know to let the final game we
played you know you got two kills killed
meet myself one which was an awesome
kill and then he also JT once so you
could see the progression of them
getting better every game oh I can't
wait till we get to the gun range yeah
now you 2 of the FN Gees over the gun
range we're gonna be shooting em for
assault rifles any [ __ ] and that was
them making up that F and G thing we
should check that play back on how nice
he really was
hey are we acting like we didn't get 20
kills the last time that was easy I was
talking about the game